Magnus and I have been around for a long
time and I think Magnus is clearly the
best player who's ever played chessar is
obviously one of the very best players
in the world certainly he has the best
results he's the highest rating in
history what is maybe the most
challenging about his style is his
resilience and also his ability to
calculate his end games are better than
anyone else in the world I don't think
it's even closed he does have a
psychological Edge just like people have
to do something special to be him you
know with Magnus will be a fo fought
game from start to
finish that's one of the challenges that
motivates me whenever I play him he is
the world champion he is the best player
in the world and I really do enjoy the
challenge I have beaten Magnus and I
think I have very good chances to win
there may come a time when I don't
consider myself a favorite for a
tournament but that time is not
now